[Aplausos]
são milhares os populações a cada
momento
em uma aula ao som do celular na tela do
celular a um clique
nós estamos expostos a qualquer tipo de
informação em vários tipos de tela e da
mãe
bom é isso não é diferente no ambiente
universitário
então nós temos que perceber que será
que nós estamos sendo formados melhores
cidadãos e preparados no mercado de
trabalho
será que isso é uma realidade bom esses
ambientes esses dois mundos mercado de
trabalho ambiente universitário eles são
bem diferentes
é verdade sendo que ele já estão
conversando e nós temos que perceber que
realmente isso é está acontecendo agora
e é claro que nós temos sim expectativas
e das diversas em qualquer um em
qualquer das situações sendo que a gente
pode ser de ter expectativas
aquela paquera da escola naquele
processo seletivo importante naquela
prova difícil mas temos que perceber que
são oportunidades de fazer as conexões
reais com outras pessoas
independente do ambiente ambiente esteja
inserido bom e se estão pensando
mas não é sempre assim as expectativas
podem não se tornar realidade
óbvio a questão é a cobrança ela vai
sempre existir aquele prazo aquele
projeto que não pode atrasar
aquela pessoa desligando o seu chefe no
telefone mas isso tem que ter clareza os
nossos objetivos e nossa força de
vontade para superar será quem está
buscando na realidade nossa formação
algo que seja verdadeiramente real para
nós mesmo ambiente o que está buscando é
o reconhecimento da estabilidade
é apenas isso é apenas uma carreira bem
estruturada
será que nós estamos em busca de
dinheiro ou será que nós estamos em
busca de uma formação melhor de se
tornar uma pessoa que você gostaria
realmente de ser bom
hernan na escola bastante tempo atrás eu
me perguntei o seguinte eu quero daqui
pra frente eu percebi uma pessoa que
gosta bastante de matemática
mamãe sempre falou que eu gostava de
computação e ficar muito tempo na frente
do computador ano foi uma coisa muito
tranquila para mim pensar que gostava
bastante de computação e lá fui eu
mergulhei em seu ambiente sou um nerd
convite acho que o nerd que gosta muito
de humanas e também das áreas
tecnológicas
mas mesmo assim é uma coisa que é
realidade para mim fez sentido e eu
nunca fui uma pessoa de gostar muito de
estudar eu sempre me dedicava a prestar
atenção porque as pessoas estavam
passando pra mim naquele ambiente e isso
começou a fazer bastante sentido quando
eu me preparei com ambientes
inspiradores ainda na universidade
ambientes inspiradores e inovadores
esses que eu falo aqui o som ambiente
onde nos coloca um desafio onde tinha
apresentado a outras pessoas e isso faz
com que seja verdade o que a gente está
querendo nossos anseios e eu tive a
oportunidade de participar de várias
ambiente como esse
e eu gosto mas a gente acaba se
perguntando qual é a nossa história
em alguns processos pela vida alguém vai
acabar te perguntando quem é você
as suas fraquezas quais são os pontos de
fortaleza o que você sabe e isso
começava a me incomodar porque eu não
sabia
isso é complicado sendo que com a ajuda
e justamente dessa rede dessa conexão
toda que atualmente me move
isso começa a fazer mais sentido
um belo dia ele recebeu a ligação de uma
professora e ela falava assim jean
você acha que a gente passar daqui pra
frente a dar aulas para outras pessoas
anime amigos seus da graduação
mas uma aula diferente uma aula onde o
assunto o conteúdo fossem criados por
essas pessoas que estejam presentes ali
no momento pensei comigo a roça no
ambiente universitário que eu conheço o
tipo de jaú é esta estava muito longe do
que eu entendi inspire e tinha
experiência na universidade como aula
aula aula sem formação crítica sem senso
de responsabilidade
sem cunho social muitas vezes em que
estava e é uma verdade muito crua pra
mim e com essa ligação a ficha começou a
cair
eu tive a responsabilidade de entrar num
projeto onde as pessoas realmente
colaboravam eu comecei a aprender isso
descansou fazer muito
muita verdade para mim realmente traz a
amizades verdadeiras ali dentro
saber que a educação é uma coisa que se
compartilha e foi esse o primeiro
ambiente inovador que eu tive contato
isso me inspirou de uma forma e aí sim
eu comecei a vivenciar algo e começar a
ficar apaixonado por educação e também
me coloquei à disposição e à frente de
começar a trabalhar com um como
voluntário em certas em certas fundações
isso fez com que o total fosse a
realidade conexão que os diferenciava
para essas pessoas
eu tive a oportunidade de transmitir o
que outras pessoas fazem de bem pra mim
para que as pessoas que estavam comigo
que eu sabia que eu podia transmitir que
tipo de conexão eu queria fazer
eu percebi e comecei a aprender e
acreditar que desenvolvimento em rede
fazia muito mais sentido do que me
fechar na minha própria bolha e começar
a aprender coisas que realmente não me
inspirava bom
seguindo essa linha de raciocínio é o
que aconteceu e aí voltando aqui
o ambiente universitário no começo eu
conheci muita gente boa nesse processo
de descoberta e em ti trouxe um buscou
trazer aqui para a universidade
o ambiente de mercado de trabalho trazer
um ambiente onde tivesse mais conexão
com uma prática do dia-a-dia e facilitar
projetos que trabalhassem tanto teórico
que a gente aprende em sala de aula com
uma prática do mercado de trabalho que
lembra lá atrás
aquelas cobranças isso ia voltar em
algum momento em que estava vivenciando
esse ambiente na universidade
participando do movimento empresa júnior
são empresas que estão dentro do
ambiente universitário e que trabalham
com projetos tocados totalmente por
alunos e mais uma vez fui lá aprendendo
a trabalhar em grupo a pena compartilhar
e aprendendo a me apaixonar também por
gestão
isso vai fazer parte daqui dessa
história pra frente
na minha vida como uma total de opção e
imagine eu lá né de computação gostava
bastante dessas coisas
e lá na empresa júnior terá a
responsabilidade de tocar uma área de
gente comigo mas eu não conheço nada
disso é um desafio realmente grande
sendo que agora já tem comigo conexões
com pessoas
isso me deu total vontade e segurança de
ir pra frente vamos lá cantando junto e
aprendemos juntos como isso aqui
acontece
e aí aconteceu essa experiência durou
por três anos e foi bem rica que se a
gente pode se eu posso resumir a minha
experiência em uma palavra seria
propósito foi o que ficou muito claro
nesses ambientes inovadores e
inspiradores para mim
a propósito como um objetivo claro onde
eu quero chegar daqui pra frente
o meu caminho
sei responder onde eu quero chegar e
como eu quero chegar lá ou isso ainda
está em construção
isso começou a ficar mais claro pra mim
a partir do momento que eu me coloquei
nessas situações
participei dessas vivências poucas
pessoas bom psicólogo daniel burman de
seguinte a uma lacuna entre o que
líderes esperam de recém formados e o
que exige recém-contratados oferecem
isso é uma realidade
nós somos cobrados todo dia por isso por
essa diferença entre esses mundos que
nós não podemos parar por aí
nós somos responsáveis por superar
nossos próprios medos e não se engane
vergonha de falhar e errar vai uma hora
nos paralisar mas temos que ter
autoconhecimento pais suficiente para
percebermos que temos que nos colocar à
disposição estar presentes no ambiente
a outra pessoa está com você percebe que
isso é uma realidade isso te move não se
coloque o presente sempre busca algo que
a gente como nike isso de verdade se
coloque diga sim ao convite ea vida vai
te oferecer
dessa maneira é que a gente vai acabar
descobrindo esses ambientes tão
inspiradores inovadores assim em
qualquer realidade não só no ambiente
universitário
com todos esses ambientes que eu
experimentei que eu vivenciei que eu
troquei tanto me fizeram hoje uma pessoa
muito mais empreendedora e uma pessoa
capacitadas para tapá sando isso pra
frente e aprendendo muito com isso
hoje eu sou empreendedor na área de
educação trabalha com educação
transdisciplinar
nada mais real pra mim do que isso
porque fazer essa conexão entre redes de
conhecimento perceber que o mundo não é
só quadradinhos
acho que esses quadrados se conectam e
que a gente precisa fazer parte dessa
conexão é nossa responsabilidade é
argumento suficiente para provocar essa
mudança
percebem eu acho que criar condições
para que esse desenvolvimento seja real
e isso é uma coisa que é bastante
verdade pra mim e bastante verdade
quando eu percebi que essas conexões vão
fazer uma pessoa melhor
em qualquer situação seja ela como amigo
como filho como aluno como responsável
então essa visão inspiradora nos cabe
para criar situações para realmente
derrubar vários mundos muito comum é
como nós quisermos não se engane
nós aprendemos fazendo o futuro pode sim
ser criado para maior conexão entre as
pessoas
isso é verdade e isso me inspira numa
forma que eu não consigo controlar e com
gosto de transbordar isso para as
pessoas que estão próximas de mim eu sou
jean e eu estou ajudando a derrubar
muros de uma formação do século passado
legado
[Aplausos]